JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hi,
I'm Jarek Wilkiewicz.
And I want to tell you about
the fun holiday project
I got to work on last year.
Every year, a few
Googlers get together
to pinpoint where Santa is
on his journey from the North
Pole.
To help users pass the time
while waiting for Santa,
we built the open source Google
Santa Tracker app for Android.
The app contains several fun
activities for its users.
For example, one can balance
sweets on candy canes,
try to find the matching bunny,
or snap a jet pack on an elf
and catch flying candy,
my personal favorite.
In addition to my fondness
for the elf jet pack game,
let me share another
little secret with you.
I am a pretty forgetful person.
Oftentimes, I use
and enjoy an app,
and then I forget all about it.
What's even more scary is
knowing that I am not alone.
While users install more
and more mobile apps,
many of the apps just
sit there, forgotten.
So I thought to
myself, I can't let
this happen to Santa Tracker.
I need to save elf jet
pack from obscurity.
But how?
Personally, I often
rely on the Google app
to keep track of stuff
I'm likely to forget.
Wouldn't it would be nice
if the Google app knew
how to take me back
into the elf jet pack
without having to remember
which app to launch
and what button to tap?
But how can a developer make
it possible for the user
to find the elf jet
pack with Google Search?
Let's think about
it for a second.
To get me back into the
elf jet pack activity,
the Google app needs
to know that a,
I use the Santa Tracker app
to play elf jet pack and b,
how to get me back
into the game I played.
The former can be achieved
using the App Indexing
API, the latter, by adding
support for deep links.
Let's start with the deep links.
What are deep links?
Think of them as a way to
identify a specific piece
of content or
functionality inside
of the mobile application, much
like web URLs, but for apps.
You can see an example here.
The deep links supported
by Santa Tracker
are exposed using
intent filters.
In this instance,
the intent filter
tells Android to route view
intents matching the deep link
to the jet pack activity.
OK, we're done
setting up deep links.
Now, we need to let the Google
app know that I actually
play the elf jet pack.
We can do this by integrating
the App Indexing API
into the activity life cycle.
Here's what we need to do.
First, create the
Google Play services API
client in onCreate.
Next, when the activity starts,
use the App Indexing API
to provide the screen title and
the corresponding deep link.
Finally, when the
activity stops,
we record the end of the view.
And that's all there is to it.
By adding just a
few lines of code
and configuring the
AndroidManifest.xml,
Google Search can help users
reengage with apps they already
have.
There are many ways
the App Indexing
API can apply to your app.
For instance, if you are
building a recipe app,
Google Search could
let your user jump back
into the recipe
they forgot about,
or if you were developing
a hotel reservation app,
your user could return to
the hotel view they were
in before they got distracted.
If you would like to learn more
about how you can integrate
the App Indexing API into your
own app, check out the docs.
To play the elf jet pack
and examine the source code,
you can clone the Santa
Tracker repo from GitHub.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]